all right so it is the morning after
your epic VMA performance
[Music]
2017 we have a photo of you coming to
the VMAs you were wearing your truth
hurts dress and you were sort of
underground at that time and since then
you've become one of the biggest stars
in the world and people always say oh
you're an overnight sensation but you
are not no we're working for a long time
tell me about this journey well I mean
it takes ten years to be an overnight
success period like anybody who just
pops up you know definitely laid the
groundwork and yeah I just love music so
I've been touring for a long time I've
been putting out mixtapes not been in
groups for a long time I've been playing
the flute forever study I studied music
theory and music performance and flute
so you know I was always gonna be a
career musician I just didn't know I was
gonna be you know nothing guys hands
what's very special I read this on
Twitter last night after your
performance
Liz Oh makes us feel Liz Oh gives us a
pep rally for our self esteem at every
performance the way you have embraced
yourself and this energy and the way you
uplift everyone else is so magical is
that who you've been your whole life is
this on purpose like make me feel so
happy
haha was definitely um intentional I
want to feel good like I um when I was
younger I had a friend who was always
helping me out with self-care and he
would be like you know you're gonna take
some time to meditate and you gotta eat
bagels with cream cheese he's got a
chill and I was like you're so good at
this you're so good at being happy and
he was like well I'm only good at being
happy because I was so sad I need it the
most and you know it's the same with me
like I need this music to be my therapy
because I have been so low and I refuse
to you know live life like that anymore
but this performance was so special to
me because normally I am performing for
everybody and I'm a very like hey listen
but this was more so for the women on
stage with me and it was an uplifting
moment for them like we sat in a circle
that the night before and we all just
shared our stories of how we got to this
point and how we got to this performance
and we all just kind of like realize
that we have the same insecurities and
we also had the same triumphs to achieve
so it was a big moment for us on stage
it was fabulous yeah I felt the energy
was through the roof
I know Rihanna's a big fan of yours girl
wood and I want to know when there's a
collaboration forget Justin Timberlake I
need a studio video of you with Rihanna
listen we need a video of Rihanna in the
studio period we don't know what I'm not
gonna bother cuz I know what that feels
like now so I'm gonna let her do what
she got to do but um I love Rihanna have
I heard from her has there been a DM
exchange at all um she DMV to tell me
that performs good she set the stage
like it was my side [ __ ] quote on
Entertainment Tonight tonight okay Mary
Mary I'm not trying to blow up your spot
but that was a hard-ass line I might
take that laughs I love it okay Justin
Timberlake so we saw you guys together
you know you said the project as flames
flames you know I have fun doing it like
collaborations for me are about like the
energy and the relationship I mean it's
Justin Timberlake so I'm not trying to
be like well you guys I didn't have a
good vibe with Justin Timberlake I
would've said no but now I'd still even
no matter who that person is if the vibe
is good you know something good is gonna
come from it we had a lot of fun we
laughed a lot he's got great energy and
so do i so um whatever we do will be
made from love and made for fun so who's
a better dancer um you know I definitely
am I love the video and instrument I was
like this is so Liz oh because you're
hanging back on the couch and you're
like yeah it's good yeah and Justin
Timberlake's like I hope you like me Liz
oh here I dance for you no it wasn't it
wasn't that necessarily but he gets it
okay he goes crazy like he was like I
don't know like he is hit world you know
we're all kind of living in it I love
that yeah so hustlers is coming out and
I love Jennifer Lopez so much and she
loves to collab so is there JLo is there
a world in which I during the hustler
soundtrack
hey Liz Oh cardi B JLo hahaha free oh
man that's dope I didn't even think of
it I don't know that's not in my control
you know it is a really cool movie to be
a part of I'm like damn this is a big
deal like everybody's talking about this
damn movie and I'm just so happy to have
a small part a small part that I have oh
and she asked me to be on song with her
and cardi B you know I would definitely
would say no um it would be late it will
be fun you know it's gonna be like she's
shaking shaking shaking no it's gonna be
like yes I mean it's a toss toss a cur
um what did you learn from Jennifer as
far as powerful women in music because
she's the goat I mean this is decade
number four for her I mean she's not
even just a powerful woman in music
she's just a powerful woman period like
she everything she does she goes full
throttle and she is like a winner she's
just such a winner and I and that was
kind of inspiring to see when she walked
on set I was like they have you know you
were gold medalist in my eyes and all of
the you know in the triathlon and acting
singing dancing producing being a mother
entrepreneur all of it so when she
walked on said I was kind of just like
learning from her but she's a
professional and that was the biggest
thing I was like you're professional but
you're warm and you also kind of allow
the room to take over she allowed us to
just actually be sisters on set and she
allowed us to banter and make jokes and
have fun cuz she I think she really
wanted the connection to feel real I
love that speaking of connection now
that you are a superstar we need to know
all about your love life which one I'm
asking it's gotta be crazy up in your DM
yeah now my dams are more pop into my
I'll tell you that much that's the
problem with doing what you do you don't
have time to date this guy shakka
Holland me at the bar last night
I was like four come on reason like I
just wasn't I didn't I wasn't feeling it
like I don't know what it is now but you
can't just be like you ordering all
those drinks by yourself I'll help you
carry those drinks excuse me I I feel
like it's the only way yeah no one but
it's not even that at this point because
you know where nobody tried to hot let
me before all this so if you're trying
to holler me now I don't trust it
yeah it's got to be something real about
you or like you just got to be fine as
hell either or I don't know say to the
guy last night
but but she didn't meet one of those you
would think that you could go do you
want like a like a celebs end up with
celebs because they understand the life
um I definitely feel like I understand
why they learn more why famous people
because if it's such an interesting
world and I think it is hard to
understand what it's like to have a
connection with somebody outside of all
of this these people and famous people
connects with millions of people at a
time and everybody was in love with them
and everybody wants you everybody want
to smash everybody want to be your best
friend so it's like really hard so kind
of safe siphon through like to find the
real people but I mean even famous
people can be I don't know I might just
have to marry myself again another music
video
okay little rapid-fire for you okay
besides being 100% that [ __ ] what else
would a DNA test reveal about Liz oh um
I'm black what other character is I
guess I'm I'm 100% um a hundred percent
Oh oh my god you're putting me on the
spot I'm 100% black what everything what
were you like young nerd like a bookworm
I read a lot I wrote a lot I was and
where did the neighbors will come from
Liz oh did not come from jay-z contrary
to popular belief Liz oh came from my
name is Melissa and when I was in middle
school he was all chopping our names and
putting her on it so for like a little
second I was me oh and then I was little
and then my friend he's just said my
name like Liz oh I know I like that I
like the way he said it with the two Z's
so I just changed it to Liz oh and I'm
so glad that you brought us the juice
tell me about this collaboration oh my
god I've paired up with absolute for
their new product called
absolute juice and I was so excited to
join them and partner with them because
it was like a match made in heaven
I got the juice they got the juice um
it's delicious oh my mom got faded on it
last night she had like one cup of it
was like I was like I had woke up I bet
I am drunk it gets you there it's late
it can go with champagne which is my
favorite thing in the world and then
when we got to do the creative and shoot
the videos like they it was so truth of
me and true to my brand and what I stand
for so yeah I'm having fun okay wrap
five